salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien cette vidéo c'est l'épisode
final de ma série documentaire sur le
combattant français Morgan Charrière si
vous n'avez pas vu les épisodes
précédents franchement ça sert à rien
foncez les voir avant de regarder cette
vidéo et pour ceux qui sont là depuis le
début j'espère que cet épisode va vous
plaire bon visionnage
[Musique]
d'une paroi de mon équipe qui est assez
et j'ai une fracture du plancher
orbitale donc c'est là où là il est logé
là en gros en dessous
[Musique]
j'ai le plancher qui s'est fracturé et
j'ai les bus les tendons qui sont
descendus dedans et donc il faut qu'il
remonte et que ça se referme
tu blessé je peux pas m'entraîner le FC
c'est mort je vais pas combattre avant
belle lurette donc j'ai aucun but tu
vois j'ai rien à faire rien du tout
ça a été hyper dur tu vois parce que
tout mon plan se déroule comme prévu
et là je perds deux combats de suite
[Musique]
et je me fais fracture du plancher
6 mois je peux pas m'entraîner
les fans français ils ont l'air de me
détester
le en train d'exploser en France j'y ai
participé et je suis plus là j'ai tout
perdu là tu vois
c'est une blessure c'est très grave ça
arrête des carrières
et qu'est-ce qu'il va faire mon grand
arrière ce qu'il est mort est-ce qu'il
est fini
pour Morgon on passe du tout au tout on
passe de je suis à ça d'aller à l'UFC
à je suis à ça de la fin de carrière
[Musique]
en fait c'est vrai le truc de tout le
monde est là quand il y a la lumière et
grâce à redescend il y a plus personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a rien qui me faisait envie pas de
joie de vivre la vie en gris tu vois
c'était vraiment mais vraiment tu vois
j'ai l'impression que j'avais un filtre
gris quand je me réveillais
j'arrivais pas à dormir la nuit alors
j'étais épuisé je pouvais pas dormir
insomnie
et ça fait 10 ans que je fais ça et je
suis très dur avec moi
très très dur
pourquoi je fais ça parce que je le fais
pour moi ou est-ce que je le fais pour
les autres que je le fais pour mes
coachs ce que je fais pour ma famille
non il y avait une dépression sale
hardcore
moi je lui avais dit mais va voir un
coach sportif discute avec un
psychologue parce que nous je comprends
qu'avec nous qu'il est pas envie de nous
dire son mal-être mais il faut fallait
qu'ils disent à quelqu'un
ça a été même pour moi ça me fait du mal
un peu de repenser à cette période sa
dépression elle est passée par là en
fait c'est qu'il parlait beaucoup moins
il était beaucoup plus renfermé
on l'a jamais dit mais il aurait même pu
arrêter à ce moment-là il aurait même pu
changer de voix ou je sais pas parce que
faut remonter il était il était atteint
il était atteint c'était dur
c'était dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah les bâtards les poissons
[Musique]
j'ai senti l'effort de certaines
personnes tu vois d'essayer de de me
faire sortir d'aller à des endroits de
pas me laisser mais moi en fait j'avais
besoin d'être tout seul
[Musique]
moi j'ai besoin d'être face au truc tu
vois vraiment genre une chaise face au
mur et alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait tu
vois un miroir qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
ça suffit de se mordre les doigts de
broyer du noir et tout il y a que moi
qui peut me sortir de cette situation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais si je vois je vais faire comme j'ai
toujours fait en solitaire peut compter
que sur moi et c'est reparti toi
j'ai fait comme une table rase tu vois
ma carrière est recommence maintenant
premier combat
[Musique]
là où il est compréhensible de s'arrêter
il a dit non je reviens je me soigne et
je continue mon objectif et je vais
réussir
[Musique]
71 7
et demain je dois être à 66
je pense que les gens ils pensent que
c'est quelqu'un qui va s'entraîner il
s'entraîne deux fois par jour ok c'est
dur et puis ensuite il y a le combat
mais je pense pas qu'il voit les
sacrifices je pense pas qu'ils voient
qu'effectivement il va compter ses
calories il va peser tout ce qui mange
parfois Morgan est tombé malade après
les combats tellement
quand la pression descend il peut être
malade pendant une semaine on est fou de
faire ce sport dans tous les cas c'est
c'est hyper difficile et les gens je
pense que il voit que la partie de
l'iceberg en fait il voit pas tout ce
qui se passe en dessous
allô ça va
ça va mon fils ça va super prêt à partir
ouais là on est sur la route je vais à
l'aéroport
bah génial génial
après mais ça va
Monique 400 grammes
6 kg
non là ça va il va mais il doit me
rester 5 kg que comme ça
que les gens disent que les combattants
disent c'est perdre le poids faire le
poids c'est un combat avant le combat ça
fait partie du travail d'être au poids
d'être dans ce poids de sa catégorie
pour pouvoir faire le combat c'est la
une bataille mais aussi une obligation
quand on est professionnel en combat on
dit toujours ta première obligation
c'est d'être au poids le jour tu as
signé pour un tel poids il faut que tu
sois au poids ce jour-là ça fait partie
de tes obligations c'est ton travail moi
ça va être génial ok allez bisous bon
allez bisous et puis que Julie à la
peine le chien donc c'est demain je dis
ouais c'était demain donc demain midi ok
super
allez bisous
sans passer grand
je mets le chauffage
c'est pas le thème de c'est pas le thème
de la soirée là qui fasse beau
donc on va faire en sorte que ce soit un
peu les tropiques qui fasse archi chaud
on arrive en Italie
très très gros coaching le coaching il
est dur il est très dur
je peux sortir les bras ici
je peux prendre mon téléphone
je peux regarder en film j'ai un peu
utilisé du coup il est un peu abîmé
mais ça va le faire
[Musique]
c'est de la crème pour ouvrir les pores
les transpirer
plus vite
mais plus longtemps
on part sur 20
mon corps il m'a pas facilité la tâche
là sur sur ce queting pourtant je l'ai
bien préparé et tout
toi tu es très très fort en casting je
suis très bon que si moi je suis
vraiment ce que je fais très
scientifique tout est calculé et tout ah
là c'est pas passé enfin c'est passé
mais c'était je suis allé le chercher
quoi je suis allé le chercher c'est j'ai
vraiment fait un premier combat avant le
combat je suis rentré dans le vif du
sujet là un an de son combat bah je l'ai
bien senti celui-là
et du coup j'ai perdu l'habitude de la
dureté du coaching tu en faut vraiment
être très mentalement à l'affronter
on est pas mal
[Musique]
on peut pas s'imaginer à quel point
c'est dur maintenant il peut perdre
connaissance c'est un travail un mental
pour faire pour faire ça et moi j'évite
d'être là j'évite d'être là et les soirs
de cutting je dors pas je dors pas tant
qu'il m'a pas dit je suis au poids
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une expérience à part de
la vie ça c'est un truc que tu peux pas
connaître si tu l'as fait pas tu peux
même pas expliquer c'est quoi la
sensation de lancer
à ce point-là
mais quand tu le fais enfin quand tu
l'as fait que tu as réussi et tu
reprends bien c'est une vraie prouesse
et ça donne beaucoup de confiance en soi
dans la vie de tous les jours
[Musique]
c'est un peu ça le sport
quand j'ai le visage creusé comme ça et
les yeux qui rentrent là comme ça quand
j'ai plus d'abdos que qu'un être humain
normal j'en ai
j'en ai 8 9 j'en ai au milieu aussi là
c'est que je suis au poil
voilà peser et là Morgan elle a pesé il
est tendu je me rappellerai toujours
sous son épaule il me disait me touche
pas laisse-moi tranquille me donne pas
tes mauvaises ondes là mais moi aussi
j'étais stressé en essayant de le
rassurer lui c'est de me rassurer moi
j'étais stressé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc manque de respect manque de
professionnels la puissance à quelques
kilos elle peut être vraiment différente
ça peut vraiment beaucoup jouer sur
l'impact des coups c'est pour ça qu'il y
a des catégories c'est pour ça que la
catégorie des plumes est à 66 et celle
des léger est à 70 il y a que 4 kilos
d'écart on pourrait se dire c'est pas
grand chose mais en fait c'est énorme
[Musique]
je
voulais faire le combat mais à son poids
quand on se mette d'accord pour
combattre à son poids sauf que moi je
faisais 66 kg c'est trop tard tu vois
ciao lui dire mais je m'en fous que ce
soit introduire genre tu crois que je me
suis amusé tu vois genre faire le poids
c'est le baba de notre métier
je pense qu'à sa place moi j'ai envoyé
tout péter à un moment donné il a une
résistance de dingue ce mec c'est un
truc de fou
tant mieux
[Musique]
joue sa carrière sur ce combat donc il
peut pas être dans sa mentalité de début
de carrière de dire quoi qu'il arrive je
vais me taper je m'en fous ce qui va se
passer non non parce que là même si il
fait une guerre même si c'est un combat
spectaculaire si il perd les
conséquences seront terribles pour lui
donc il n'accepte pas ça c'est moi qui
dois choisir là si je prends le combat
c'est tout ce travail de préparation il
est très dur mentalement et quand on n'a
pas la récompense la carotte au bout du
combat de pouvoir s'exprimer et faire
son métier parce que son métier à
Morgant c'est de combattre dans une cage
il y a beaucoup de frustration ok les
gars bah du coup comme vous en doutez
j'ai vu que l'impôt était déjà sorti en
plus je vais pas combattre demain ça
fait partie de la vie de Fighter toute
façon donc voilà ça la vie continue
j'espère que j'aurai un combat
prochainement contre quelqu'un respecte
ce sport et ses règles et puis bah on se
voit pour la suite on n'a pas de chance
c'est comme ça
c'est vraiment dur d'être dans ces
positions là et c'est sans doute ou un
des sports les plus compliqués à gérer
mentalement quand on est dans une
mauvaise phase après cet annulation de
combat mort gant pousse sur les réseaux
sociaux et je pense que le camp Morgan
Charrière pousse aussi le quai joueur
pour dire il nous faut une date de
combat faut qu'on soit actif et il y a
ce combat contre
on est sur un combat où il faut pas se
louper on peut pas se permettre d'avoir
cette troisième défaite de suite
dans sa tête il se dit c'est mon combat
de retour
ça fait un an que j'ai pas combattu si
je prends un troisième rouge à mon
retour c'est fini
un Bazin
et c'est pas n'importe qui
il est fort il est vraiment fort lui il
est sur 4 5 victoires d'affilée il vient
de battre deux anciens combattants de
l'UFC mais je me dis impossible je peux
pas perdre trop bas j'ai pas le droit de
le perdre tu vois
moi je lui ai dit bah mon gars on a fait
la théorie on a fait les stratégies tout
mais je lui dis lui il faut qu'on le
marbre il faut qu'on le montre qu'on est
revenu
tu peux pas avancer dans le sport c'est
impossible
il amène au sol l'outil défense super
bien le texte
et le mec en face il se prend des
parpains plein de bouche il se prend non
il y a le nombre de fois où il le touche
au corps basant il devrait tomber
donc soit le mec c'est un cyborg soit
il est bien complémenté
[Musique]
du coup on s'est retrouvé avec un basant
qui a touché qui était très fort qui a
fatigué Morgan
[Musique]
je me voyais pas prendre une troisième
défaite comme ça là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans une situation qu'on a trop souvent
vu avec Morgan décision partagée et là
si vous êtes fan de fan de Morgan vous
bon ça risque de se compliquer
[Musique]
mais dans une situation on est même
stressé pour lui oh squatter ces jeunes
[__] non pas maintenant on va encore
se faire [__]
[Musique]
voilà la délivrance
mais là on met le cours toute seule je
remets mes lunettes parce qu'on a un peu
dignité quand même on a un verre dans le
bilan et on peut repartir d'attaque pour
la suite et surtout il y a cette envie
chez Morgan de recombat très vite et
puis de se dire l'UFC dans un coin de sa
tête c'est possible
moi Morgan Charrière on n'a jamais parié
ne serait-ce qu'une seule pièce sur moi
j'ai toujours été de l'autre cyder je ne
suis pas du genre à lâcher je suis
beaucoup trop têtu ça va marcher pour
moi j'en suis persuadé
sachez une chose je compte bien
continuer à écrire l'histoire qui m'est
destinée et le prochain chapitre de ma
carrière il aura lieu en Irlande le 29
avril
dans sa tête il y a plein de il y en a
marre les gars
[Musique]
il a changé de façon de combat qui
combat différemment il développe une
violence qu'il avait pas avant
il fait peur
il fait peur je l'ai jamais vu comme ça
ok là il a fallu que je réactive la
machine et maintenant vous allez voir le
Morgan 2.0 parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de changements
quand j'ai vu le combat j'ai vu que mort
quand c'était lumen du tout
moi je lui dis on le prend pas à la
légère il faut pas le prendre à la
légère il faut qu'on le respecte il faut
qu'on le rentre dedans mais faut rien
lui laisser
on commence le combat c'est un petit
échange et bim une amené au sol boum tag
prise de dos non non non non non non
[__]
mais morgons on le voit le panique pas
[Musique]
là il a repris son temps il a laissé 3
minutes passer quand même
il a d'abord sécurisé il y a vraiment
step by step
et une fois qu'il est sorti maintenant
c'est ce qu'il m'a dit il était hyper
énervé en fait
il a jamais tapé un mec aussi fort que
ça jamais c'était violent c'était hyper
violent
il fracasse pas c'est le récipient de
trois années de frustration à plein de
niveaux si vous aimez c'est les
annulations de combat Sousa c'est
malheureux pour toi mais là tu as mangé
toute la frustration de Morgan
[Musique]
et là le médecin rentre dans la cage
faut savoir que quand le médecin parle
il te donne trois commandes avec
l'arbitre et si tu vois que tu réponds
pas de manière intelligible il peut
arrêter le combat
la
réduit du médecin
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais vu comme ça c'est de très
très bonne
[Musique]
avant il arrivait sur le riz c'était pas
violent mais maintenant on sent que ça y
est ça on crée ça arrive les plus animal
et les féroces maintenant il casse la
gueule il tabasse quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
être le meilleur
c'est important d'être le meilleur si
vous faites quelque chose et vous vous
lancez pas pour être le meilleur ne le
faites pas ça sert à rien si il faut
faire de la peu près ne le faites pas
faut pas se porter l'oeil et qu'on veut
pas non plus on a toujours en tête se
dire le FC vient à Paris en septembre
[Applaudissements]
et si et si c'était possible et si ça se
faisait
[Musique]
Morgane
c'est vraiment sale sentiment
de faire briller le MMA et de marquer
son sport
UFC Paris
pour moi c'est plus un rêve c'est
vraiment j'y suis quoi
l'UFC je répète Morgan Charrière va
combattre à l'UFC moi je vois pas ce qui
peut arrêter un combattant comme ça tout
est possible tout est possible
là la suite là elle va être hyper
déterminante pour ma vie je sais même
pas ma carrière pour ma vie
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette série sur
Morgan j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
autant que moi j'ai pris du plaisir à la
tournée avec lui je prends deux secondes
aussi pour remercier les équipes qui
m'ont aidé à réaliser cette série parce
que évidemment je suis pas tout seul il
y a pas de l'eau qui l'a monté à une
vitesse éclair à un grand merci à lui je
pense aussi à Emma Karim Mathias Nicolas
et à tous les autres et qui m'ont aidé
c'est toujours un travail d'équipe un
grand merci aussi à RMC Sport et
Laurence salvoon qui nous ont beaucoup
aidé pour qu'on puisse réaliser cette
série merci aussi à vous pour votre
soutien et d'avoir été présent pour
regarder cette série n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne Youtube de brut
pour ne pas rater les prochains
documentaires merci encore à très vite